an unusual man mr. Berg
[Applause]
speaks 7li
you're an athlete you're more than up
the physical requirements of the job
what job since this war began we have
reason to believe the Germans are
working on the fission bomb scientists
leading the atomic program is Anna
Hassan book
we must get to him and find out how
close the Germans are to a bomb
welcome to the OSS mr. Berg millions of
lives at stake a 5% chance of losing the
war to a weapon like this you do what
has to be done you can't allow yourself
to be captured you know that I love you
you brought me here to say goodbye
I'll be back this your first job
never killed a man
it's not as hard as you like that I
don't know what God you believe in Berg
if any I'll be asking mine to keep it on
me
what at Heisenberg's of our side when
you open he'll defect there comes down
to it
are you going to be able to kill him
[Music]
there may be one moment that tells you
whether the Germans having bomb
one moment when you learn all you need
to know
[Music]
no more
you
you